je suis partagé moi j'attends de voir
effectivement le le texte en détail mais
je pense que le droit de grève il est
déjà encadré il y a déjà un service
minimum normalement qui qui doit
s'exercer après c'est aussi la
responsabilité des syndicats c'est à
dire que le droit de grève il est
constitutionnel et il faut le défendre
après ça ne peut pas non plus être un
droit de blocage et un droit de pourrir
la vie des Français et donc
effectivement le fait de bloquer les
transports au moment du départ en
vacances au moment d'un certain nombre
d'événements de regroupement familial je
pense notamment au fait de Noël comme on
a pu le vivre dernièrement ça ce n'est
pas normal ce n'est pas responsable donc
moi j'appelle plutôt à la responsabilité
des syndicats plutôt que d'organiser une
limitation du droit de grève qui est un
droit encore une fois constitutionnel et
que je défends
[Musique]